nous sommes le mardi 22 novembre 2016
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 les inviter celles et ceux qui font
l'actualité dans le département des
yvelines voici le sommaire invité
aujourd'hui henri fall en charge de la
communication des restos dans le
département des yvelines il évoque cette
32ème campagne il nous livre ses
priorités et ses inquiétudes aussi face
à la hausse des demandes des plus jeunes
et des plus âgés
et puis sortir du burn out alors qu'un
colloque qu'un colloque vient de se
tenir à versailles sur la question le
témoignage d'une victime et de son
combat pour retrouver son équilibre à la
32ème campagne d'hiver des restos du
coeur qui débute donc les distributions
alimentaires viennent de se tenir
notamment ce matin et de nouveau un
record devrait être battu comment
réagissent elle est bénévole comment
s'organise t il dans les yvelines invité
henri fall bonsoir bonsoir est en charge
notamment de la communication dans le
département yvelinois comment s'est
déroulé tout simplement cette première
journée de distribution
la première journée s'est comme
d'habitude
donc c'est un peu de bousculade
les gens reprennent leur marque les
nouveaux bénévoles les nouveaux
bénéficiaires
et c'est reparti avec quand même pub de
l' enthousiasme beaucoup pour tous nos
bénévoles beaucoup de choses qui restent
il ya toujours de la pauvreté mais des
choses qui changent
qu'est ce qui a changé par exemple sur
ceux des longues quand sur ce début de
campagne on a ouvert un centre à
sartrouville je crois que ça fait cinq
ans que je viens vous voir cinq ans je
disais qu'on a cherché à ouvrir un
centre à sartrouville en a ouvert un
centre à sartrouville et là je remercie
la municipalité de sartrouville qui nous
a trouvé des locaux tout ça c'est super
l'an dernier neuf cent vingt-six mille
personnes ont été accueillies lors de la
campagne cela représente 130 2 5
millions de repas distribués jeu
pourrait même pousser un peu plus le
chiffre jusqu'à presque 2 milliards
depuis la création tout de même 7 des
restos ça représente quoi l'échelle des
yvelines à l'échelle des yvelines
c'est un million quatre cent mille repas
distribués à 14000 personnes et c'est un
chiffre en progression
oui ça peut prévu pour cent de plus les
derniers on était un peu plus de 13000
là on est à 14 milles et vous vous
attendez encore cette année hélas cette
forme sort les inscriptions sont en
cours mais on sent que oui ça risque
parce que la police chiffre à mais ça
risque de enfin les on est en avance les
inscriptions par rapport à l'année
dernière
là aussi chaque année vous revenez vous
nous expliquer que la pauvreté progresse
le constat est toujours le même constat
les plus jeunes les plus âgés font
partie des démunis les congas fait de
plus en plus à celle de tuya des jeunes
il ya beaucoup de jeunes il ya eu un
reportage je crois sur le film semble
sur lequel ils montraient qu'il y avait
énormément d'étudiants jeunes je crois
que c'était sur toulouse qui venait aux
restos du coeur
nous on a ça et alors d'ailleurs devant
cette constat de plus de gens qui qui
travaillent leur soient étudiées travail
étudiant soit ils travaillent pauvres
mais ils travaillent mais ils n'ont pas
les moyens de joindre les deux bouts
on a inauguré cette année l'ouverture le
samedi de rambouillet donc ce sera entre
deux distributions de rambouillet voir
le samedi voyons change un peu on essaye
de s'adapter de mieux accueillir
on va on va évoquer toutes vos activités
parce qu'on parle de cette distribution
pendant la campagne d'hiver mais il ya
toujours une activité sociale et les
relais bébé aussi qu'il fonctionne on va
revenir juste surtout ça j'aurai comme
vous faire réagir sur sur ce chiffre 8
millions 5 de français qui vivent en
2007 sous le seuil de pauvreté
on arrive sur et on est même en pleine
campagne préélectorale électorale en ce
moment est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
que les élus les candidats les
différents candidats prennent conscience
de ce problème et apporte des solutions
est ce que vous vous sentez rassuré pour
l'avenir
je suis pas rassuré
et en plus on en parle relativement peu
quoi on parle des minorités je trouve
dans beaucoup mais pas tellement de la
pauvreté sachant que effectivement quand
même en france on ne meurt pas de faim
ce n'est pas l'afrique mais il ya de la
pauvreté il ya des gens qui n'arrivent
pas à joindre les deux bouts
et c'est parce que on leur donne un peu
amont de la nourriture qu'ils peuvent
acheter des nouvelles chaussures pour
les enfants ou faire faire des choses
qui ferait pas autrement
alors on parle de cette aide alimentaire
et je le disais tout à l'heure les
restos aujourd'hui interviennent dans
tous les domaines que ce soit si
l'hébergement l'aide sociale quelles
sont les différentes activités sur
lesquelles vous intervenez les
différents postes donc la principale
c'est quand même l'aide alimentaire et
après on fait de l'aide à la personne
c'est alors la pauvreté il ses deux deux
choses importantes pauvreté c'est le
manque de logement de travail si elle
n'avait pas de travail ils n'avaient pas
de logement vous en sortez pas donc on
travaille sur le logement on a des
centres d'hébergement apprécié pour
essayer de faire des transitions et
trouver des logements stables et on a le
travail donc on a des centres date des
ateliers et chantiers d'insertion pour
remettre les gens au travail les
habitués à venir à l'heure en partir et
souvent c'est vaincre une addiction
souvent quel résultat vous obtenez sur
l'aide à l'insertion justement ça va à
peu près on est à peu près un peu plus
de 50% et le conseil général qui nous
subventionne en partie voudrais bien
qu'on arrive à 60 mais c'est difficile à
dire on est on est pris entre deux feux
sont reprend des gens qui sont prêts de
l'emploi et c'est facile mais c'est pas
le but qu'on a tous et prendre des fonds
qui sont très loin d'emplois et de les
ramener sur le sort de l'emploi et donc
c'est à peu près 50%
je reviens au sirop bénévoles les
bénévoles sont toujours plus nombreux
on parle de cette pauvreté qui peut
dresser en parallèle la solidarité
s'organise l'été pendant ce mois ça fait
dix ans aux restos du coeur n'était
toujours atone 900 bénévoles cette année
en passe habile à cause de l'ouverture
de sartrouville est à peu près 80
bénévoles mais mais on manque encore de
bénévoles mais sur des métiers très
particulier je vous donne deux de deux
choses enfin il pour banaliser c'est
l'occase heures voilà
sait on a besoin de bénévoles pour
l'entrepôt et pour ce qu'on appelle la
ramaz c'est à dire aller dans les
supermarchés hypermarchés et puis
prendre les produits qui sont en début
de printemps sont en date limite mais
qui vont bientôt atteindre la date
limite pour les ramasser et donc ça
c'est des métiers difficiles entre eux
procès de six heures du matin jusqu'à
midi s'est il fait froid et faim et ses
pas et puis en plus vous êtes avec de la
marchandise que vous voyez pas des gens
enfin vous voyez des gens mais ces
quelques bénévoles autour de vous donc
c'est un métier c'est difficile et là je
remercie tous les bénévoles aujourd'hui
qui sont sur les sur l'entrepôt ils font
un travail je pense surtout à jacques
fait un travail formidable formidable
mais un peu un peu quelques quelques
personnes de plus seraient les
bienvenues et pareil pourra par exemple
la ramasse à bois d'arcy pas très loin
d'ici sur leclerc d'auch cette
solidarité vous parler de ces grandes
enseignes marche aussi avec les grandes
enseignes elles sont plus à jouer le jeu
et alors à faire dans l'alimentaire
c'est un peu je veux dire elle a osé
parler des nouveautés ça fait partie de
la grande nouveauté aussi c'est de
l'augmentation de ce qu'on appelle la
substitution la substitution s'est
substitué des produits aux produits
qu'on a acheté des produits qu'on
collecte soit dans les grandes enseignes
soit
à travers des collectes nationales et
vous donne un chiffre
il ya il ya dix ans on était à 5% c'est
à dire qu'on a coûté 95 % la nourriture
et on en ramasse est donc un collectif
pour cent aujourd'hui on est à 40
et c'est la seule façon de faire si
comme nos revenus n'augmentent pas et
c'est la seule façon de faire pour
subvenir aux besoins de ces pauvres
c'est de faire de la ramasse et la loi
leur froid qu'elle s'appelle la loa
garraud qui va arriver en février nous
aide bien et donc là il ya quand même
une action gouvernementale qui est
positive très positif mobilisation pour
cette 32ème campagne d'hiver qui
débutent et vous l'avez entendu il n'y a
pas que cette distribution alimentaire
il ya aussi une aide sociale qui est à
porter au quotidien et puis aussi la
campagne d'été un parce que vous
intervenez aussi pendant les absolus
mans j'aurais juste leur souligner on le
dit à chaque fois mais les restos ne
sont pas fermées absolument
on distribue aussi pendant tout l'été
mais le lancement de la campagne d'hiver
c'est aussi une occasion avant noël et
serah de remettre une dynamique notre
mouvement on va faire appel donc à cette
solidarité le site un rôle dans
solidarité et des bénévoles
merci restosducoeur.org et vous avez
entendu le message de marie fall et ça
concerne les yvelines mais pas seulement
solidarité pour les dons solidarité
aussi pour ces bénévoles qui se
mobilisent et ils sont attendus toujours
nombreux pour venir vous aider au
quotidien merci beaucoup d'être bien
sait encore si vous prend un plateau
nous poursuivons ce 7,8 les invités avec
le syndicat cfe cgc qui organise et nous
en avions parlé le jeudi 17 novembre
dernier un colloque sur le burn out
nous avons recueilli à cette occasion un
témoignage fort celui de daniel le
meunier elle nous parle de sa situation
personnelle d'épuisement professionnel
elle s'est confiée au micro de nicolas
d'un drilles écoutez la en 2009 une
énième restructuration et je dois
m'improviser
exercer un nouveau métier chargés de
voyages pour l'entreprise je n'avais
aucune compétence en dehors d'eux
du fait d'avoir envie d'apprendre parce
que j'avais pas eu le choix me proposer
windows donc oui j'étais censé avoir des
formations pour accompagner et ont
accompagnés dans cette dans ce nouveau
métier et en fait non je n'ai pas eu de
formation et j'ai dû me former plus ou
moins sur le tas dans une ambiance qui
était avec une surcharge de travail déjà
dont dans ce service et je m'étais dit
tant pis parce que j'ai pas le choix
moi l'entreprise je l'aimais j'ai envie
de donner encore et de prouver que je
peux faire encore autre chose de nouveau
et et ça va passer ça l'a pas fait parce
que j'ai essayé de résister 2011 2012
2013 ou un sourire quand même me donne
une prime je fais un bon travail on est
en sous-effectif et j'assure et 2014 je
retombe jusqu'à ce que soir en rentrant
du travail
je mets le pied sur le frein chalet
j'allais basculé dans un fossé
parce que j'avais perdu le sommeil parce
que j'avais perdu l'appétit parce que
j'avais perdu confiance en moi de
confiance en entreprise je suis
certainement parce que je ne comprenais
pas pourquoi on me laissait dans cette
situation j'ai fait face dès le
lendemain à du silence en fait de la
part de l'employeur un monde du silence
qui est vraiment destructeurs parce que
on a besoin de parler en fait est là que
je comprenais pas ce qui m'arrive et je
comprenais pas gibier je vais retourner
bosser à un moment et tout et ils vont
m'appeler
ils vont me prendre de mes nouvelles et
j'ai attendu un mois deux mois trois
mois
huit mois et pas personne ne m'a appelé
le chsct avait lancé un droit un droit
dernière les délégués du personnel aussi
beaucoup de dégâts dans la cité
évidemment mon système nerveux et a été
impactée est abîmée j'ai un traitement
lourd lourd et je sais que je vais pas
retrouvé ma santé je sais et mes jeux
jeux chat ça c'est important pour moi
c'est ma thérapie c'est mieux qu'un
médicament
j'arrive plus à lire non plus et
j'arrive plus à tourner les pages d'un
livre depuis 30 mois et mac était
lectrice je pouvais lui à deux trois
livres par semaine et c'est fini
j'arrête pas et je dors maintenant mais
je dors parce que j ai un comprimé à
avaler c'est un sommeil sans rêves et
les règlements parce que je pense qu'on
a tous besoin de rêver et et ils me
maintenaient repérer et jeu je sais pas
comment faire j'ai envie de partager
encore plein de choses je pense que j'ai
des compétences et j'ai peut-être même
envie de retourner à l'école parce que
j'ai envie d'apprendre sur la
communication et mais aujourd'hui je
suis encore c'est encore difficile
je me sens pas encore la force d'y aller
mais ça va venir
on avait mis en images oui il va y avoir
des belles choses encore j'en suis sûr
c'est la fin du set 8 les invités pour
ce soir prochain rendez vous mercredi
18h45 d'ici là n'oubliez pas un au
replay sur le site internet en attendant
les programmes se poursuivent sur tv
fils